y
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en un nuevo
avance informativo en francés 24
comenzamos en áfrica el ex presidente de
sudáfrica jacob zuma fue sentenciado a
15 meses de prisión por no comparecer en
una investigación por corrupción durante
su mandato la investigación trata de
establecer si durante los casi nueve
años de gobierno de zuma que se extendió
entre 2009 y 2018 el aparato estatal
benefició a empresarios de forma
fraudulenta en sexting
se suman en la medida en que el señor
gay consuma ha intentado justificar su
desafío a través de declaraciones
públicas no tiene relevancia statements
en oxford malditas declaraciones no
fueron alegadas formalmente por lo que
deben ser ignoradas la corte
constitucional no puede hacer más que
concluir que el señor zuma es culpable
del delito de desacato al tribunal
contento y durante una visita histórica
de emiratos árabes unidos el
recientemente designado ministro de
relaciones exteriores de israel
yair lapid inauguró su embajada en abu
dhabi y se prepara para hacer lo mismo
con el consulado
la pit fue recibido por el ministro de
estado emiratí ahmed ali al sayed en la
primera visita de un titular de esa
cartera a esta nación árabe también es
la primera vez que israel abre una
embajada en un territorio del golfo
pérsico decisión que fue tomada luego de
que ambos países restablecieron
relaciones diplomáticas en agosto del
año pasado y siguiendo a la reapertura
días antes de la embajada de emiratos
árabes unidos en tel aviv
y en etiopía las tropas del gobierno
abandonaron mikel en la capital de la
región de tigre después de haber
declarado un cese al fuego unilateral en
una guerra que completa casi ocho meses
y que ha generado según la onu la peor
crisis alimentaria en una década el
frente de liberación popular de tigre
dijo haber retomado el control de la
zona que había quedado en manos del
gobierno central el pasado 4 de
noviembre el conflicto ha dejado miles
de muertos y obligado al menos a dos
millones de personas a huir de sus
hogares
y el secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken urgió la aceleración de
cooperación internacional con países
pobres para poner freno a la crisis
sanitaria el llamado lo hizo en la
ciudad italiana de matera allí se reúnen
este martes los ministros de exteriores
y desarrollo del g20 en su primer
encuentro presencial desde que inició la
pandemia del cob y de 19 y tal ya que
ostenta la presidencia rotatoria del g20
ha anticipado que en el debate prestará
especial atención al continente
americano
en eeuu los demócratas están impulsando
la conformación de un comité encargado
de investigar la toma del capitolio el
pasado 6 de enero la comisión estaría
conformada por 13 miembros 8 de ellos
serían designados por la presidenta de
la cámara baja nancy pelosi y otros 5 en
consulta con el líder de la minoría
republicana kevin mccarthy se espera que
el pleno de la cámara de representantes
votó la iniciativa este miércoles
en norteamérica una intensa ola de calor
azota por estos días la costa noroeste
de eeuu y la costa sureste de canadá
donde las temperaturas siguen batiendo
récords ciudades estadounidenses como
portland salem registraron temperaturas
nunca antes vistas desde que iniciaron
los registros en 1890 salen la capital
del estado de oregon alcanzó incluso los
47,2 grados celsius en british columbia
canadá cerraron escuelas y universidades
después de que el mercurio tocara los
46,6 grados celsius superando los
récords que databan de 1937
hasta que se avance quédense con
nosotros transmite